una nueva ayuda militar a ucrania
eeuu destinará 800 millones de dólares
en asistencia y equipará con nuevo
material antiaéreo al ejército ucraniano
continuamos con el flujo de armas a
ucrania y utilizando mi autoridad
presidencial active en mayor asistencia
de seguridad para ayudar a ucrania a
frenar el ataque ruso con 800 millones
de dólares adicionales estos el anuncio
de bailén se vio después del discurso de
volodymyr selenski ante el congreso
estadounidense allí pidió de nuevo más
sanciones más ayuda y la exclusión aérea
es demasiado pedir crear una zona de
exclusión aérea sobre ucrania para
salvar a las personas de estos demasiado
desde el inicio del conflicto ucrania ha
sufrido su notable inferioridad aérea
contra rusia algo que ha ocasionado
numerosos bombardeos contra las
principales ciudades del país durante
las últimas semanas el refuerzo militar
a ucrania ha ido acompañado de sanciones
contra rusia medidas económicas que
tienen el objetivo de debilitar la
campaña de moscú aunque su presidente
negó que hayan causado
no lograron organizar una guerra
económica relámpago contra rusia para
desmoralizar a nuestra sociedad para
atacarnos de frente por lo tanto es
probable que veamos intentos de aumentar
la presión a nuestro país pero también
superaremos estas dificultades la
economía rusa se adaptará a la nueva
realidad la guerra en ucrania cumple su
tercera semana con la perspectiva de que
si no se llega a un acuerdo el conflicto
podría estancarse y convertirse en uno
de larga duración